[Applause]
low-key it's arrogant to have a window
yeah we're in quarantine woody would
like like Mitchell's on your head
arrogant like like we live in such a
safe society that we assume people
aren't gonna break in and steal [ __ ]
they're like if you go down Broadway
right or Fifth Avenue there are giant
glass windows glasses that thick you
could knock on that [ __ ] it breaks and
there are thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise
just right another side of the window
and after they close you know what the
place is do sometimes they leave the
lights on they almost like we should
have been broken down always have had
windows to the bank glass doors for the
bank you never see the [ __ ] movie
when they break into the bank and they
look in the window of Jabal and they see
well they got money in there I was going
that one right because they notice [ __ ]
just worked it you never see one movie
where they did that right and which ball
should we break it to well look at all
the windows let's see what's in there
first bro in storage wars the whole idea
is you got to choose it before you look
you got windows doors Wars they don't
have windows and storage wars yeah I
know but you know the point of Windows
right what's the point of Windows or
window shopping yeah exactly
so that's why they gotta have windows
and where you might buy some kit know
where doors anybody walking by storage
you know like yo let me buy that first
floor window it's arrogant Windows is a
[ __ ] girl wearing no clothes hey
that's what I'm not trying to make them
blame right now Windows is a girl with a
low-cut shirt she goes like oh yeah you
probably that's what they doin a walking
around ask why we looking them titties
bro and I'm not saying we supposed to
grab them with sex with avenues are
winking at me do ya'll say like you
literally you have blinking lights in
the window you have some blinking lights
go and look at this [ __ ] this mad
expensive and nobody's around
it says closed on the door it's like
y'all we're not here hey it's closed but
we left some light on in case you want
to take this fire [ __ ] Loki Loki they
deserve - [ __ ] Loki broke me amen you
make a convincing Kerrigan is it not
Erik like in your apartment if you live
on the first floor right you put some
bars on your [ __ ] window don't you
mm-hmm
cuz you're like you know I live in a
first floor [ __ ] you break away
that right in I'm not gonna allow that
[ __ ] mm-hmm I have a neighbor when I was
growing up famous person his windows had
blackout curtains so you couldn't even
see what was inside it was and what I
mean blackout curtains is so you can
have the room dark inside no no I'm
crazy all dirty crazy boy there's no
black square phrase it wrong they had a
specific type of curtain that they could
see out and get all the light out
you it was like a mirror thing you know
when they do like a two-way mirror yeah
it was like a two-way mirror essentially
what a courier I got you guys so it was
like but of course it's like yo it's
arrogant this arrogant well hey just
sayin I don't think people are going to
go around breaking laws that's arrogant
that's how arrogant we got is we thought
that you just get to keep your stuff
yeah I remember when I was in middle
school I learned that I had a North Face
I thought I was wearing and this son was
like give me that and I was like it's
mine
and he goes I want it and I was like I
quit [ __ ] that you thought was yours
could not be he was like well you ain't
have no glass around you
[Applause]